Fox News host Tucker Carlson is really
good at many things and one of those
things is couching what we all on the
Left suspect are really unsavory and
disgusting political opinions as sort of
rock-solid logical expressions of just
where the facts take Tucker Carlson and
he does this so well that he's really
good at appearing not to be a hateful
conservative but a compassionate one
someone who is led to conservative
policy not by pejorative beliefs about
others but because common sense and his
desire for everything to be better for
everyone has led him to be a
conservative that's sort of the
character he's developed on Fox News
it's pretty transparent but Tucker's
really good at it and it's particularly
effective with the Fox News audience
that he caters to he makes the Fox News
audience feel like he and they are
right-wing not because they're bad
people or their priorities are wrong or
they are ignorant but for nice fluffy
reasons that everybody can feel pretty
good about except we know that lurking
behind that are the same disgusting
unpolished ideas that we see at Donald
Trump's rallies and that we see outside
of CPAC and case in point there is some
recently unearthed audio which features
Tucker Carlson straight-up saying women
are primitive and just need to be quiet
and do what they're told it's shocking
but it's really not all that surprising
when you actually remember Tucker
Carlson years and years ago and what his
career has actually been this both of
these clips are from the Bubba the Love
Sponge show years and years ago but not
so long ago that Tucker Carlson wasn't
an adult with beliefs that he came up
with on his own take a listen to the
first clip you know in my brief
experience you know gets women going is
arguing with them really yeah honey
non-brand I never use it it's true you
debate politics with a woman and just go
you know just full-blown out there
especially feminism if you're talking to
a feminist and she's giving you well you
know men really need to be more
sensitive and this you know actually men
don't need to be more sensitive you just
be quiet and kind of do what you're told
and lighten up a little bit they love it
and then we get to the part about women
being primitive so hey let's go crazy
how old are your daughter
14 I love women but they're extremely
primitive their basic they're not that
hard to understand okay
so now what right well Tucker Carlson
has put out a tweet about this where he
says quote Media Matters caught me
saying something naughty on a radio show
more than a decade ago rather than
Express the usual usual ritual
contrition how about this I'm on
television every weeknight live for an
hour if you want to know what I think
you can watch so opting not to do one of
these bogus apologies which people often
do I totally understand his reasoning
there and taking this as an opportunity
to plug his show so what should happen
I've been getting emails from people
saying David are you going to call for
Tucker Carlson's firing David are you
going to call for an ad boycott of
Tucker Carlson no I'm not I mean I'm not
suggesting Tucker Carlson be fired for
this these are common beliefs among
Tucker Carlson and a lot of people in
his audience and a lot of the Fox News
audience why would they fire him for
merely reflecting what the views are of
the audience I'm not going to call for
an advertiser boycott of Tucker Carlson
if advertisers understand that these are
Carlson's views and these are the views
of a lot of his audience if they don't
mind being associated with them it's
still probably a pretty good financial
decision to advertise with Tucker
Carlson so I'm not calling for an ad
boycott either I'm guessing that a bunch
of Tucker's new friends
if Tucker Carlson were to be targeted
for a firing for an ad boycott or
whatever would say this is another
example of the triggered language
policing left who are trying to get him
fired just over jokes and it's
censorship and free speech and bla bla
bla bla bla First Amendment let's just
all agree that we understand
this is the underlying ideology here
period the facade of the smart logical
triggering the lives Libs non-ugly
conservatism of carlson who's this great
debater and has the moral high ground
and the factual high ground it's just
fake okay he's just that he is a facade
for the exact right-wing beliefs that we
know underlie their ideology period he
doesn't have to be fired foxnews
probably is hiring him or hired him
because of that not despite that if you
go and look at the comments on articles
about this leaked or unearthed audio i
guess is a better leak doesn't really
make sense unearthed audio on Reddit and
on The Daily Beast and everywhere that's
writing about it you will find the
comments section riddled with people who
say Tucker is right he should be
applauded there's nothing wrong with
what he's saying women are primitive
they should just be quiet and do what
they're told there's nothing wrong with
what Tucker is saying and if you find it
offensive it's because you're a
triggered liberal that can't handle the
truth so let's skip the Tucker should be
fired
Tucker is exactly where he should be
these views and Fox News and Fox News's
audience is exactly where this stuff all
makes sense and is sort of harmonious
and it's just up to advertisers to
decide whether they're ok with it and if
they are it's going to continue to be
profitable for them to advertise on Fox
News evaluate Tucker on the reality of
what he actually stands for rather than
this vague notion of a guy who has
simply been driven by the facts to be a
conservative and then we can move on
with our day and continue consuming the
media that we find is useful or relevant
to us if you disagree with me if you
think we should be calling for his
firing or for an ad boycott let me know
I'm on Instagram at David Pakman the
show is on Instagram at David Pakman
show